uh so maybe i'm just a romantic but good
luck saying love is conditional to a
romantic partner
i mean you could
i would argue on mass
that would uh deteriorate the quality of
relationships
uh if you remind the partner of that
truth that is universal like you have to
the
i mean okay maybe it's just me i'll just
speak to myself it's like there's a
certain romantic notion of unconditional
love it's part of why
you have so many destructive marriages
it's it's part of why that's a problem
yes it's it's a real problem because
because
yes there there is a you are talked
about honoring your spouse and and
there's a real truth there and i i i
respect that yes you have to do certain
things love is not you marry somebody
and there's a real attitude out there in
the culture you marry somebody and okay
now we're gonna we're just gonna cruise
it's just right hollywood that's that's
the hollywood map you know marriage is
work it it it it's like all values it's
work it it's something you have to
reignite every day you have to you have
to the challenges the real disagreements
the
the the the things you you fight about
you disagree about and and there's real
if it's a value you work it out you you
you you struggle through it you you
and and sometimes you struggle through
it you come to a conclusion nah this is
not gonna work and and you dissolve a
marriage and i'm i'm all for dissolving
after
really really fighting for it because if
it's an important value and if you fell
in love with this person for a reason
then that's something worth fighting for
i have a feeling that hollywood goes the
other way but it's not this cruising
along and everything everything is easy
no human relationship is like that
enough friendship not love not not not
raising children not being a child um
you know they require work and and they
require thinking and they require
creating the conditions
to thrive and that's the sense in which
it's it's conditional you you have to
look at it and it it it's in in
it's very easy
not to do the work and it's very easy to
drift away and i think most people don't
do the work most people take it and and
generally in life they the only place
people seem to work is at work
and then they take the rest of their
life as i'm gonna cruise and yet every
aspect of your life the art you choose
the friends you choose the lovers you
choose
all require real thinking and real work
to be successful at them none of them
are just
just there because there is no such
thing as just the intrinsic right i
agree with all of that i was going to
say before that that the rabbis have
this
sort of shocking expression
raising children and uh
i i find when i speak to audiences about
relationships i find that that in
general and this is a this is
cross-cultural it's with different
countries different religious
backgrounds that in general
young people
do not know that the only way to make a
marriage work is through a lot of pain
and overcoming they don't know that
raising children involves a great deal
of pain they don't know that caring for
and helping your parents approach the
end of their lives
causes a great deal of pain and and
everything is kind of this sketchy you
know very very sketchy glimpsy kind of
and i i mentioned hollywood just because
it it it it everything is made to look
easy except you know there's kind of a
funny breakdown of something but then it
you know maybe there's a divorce they
you know they shoot one another so
that's so then they should get divorced
but
but the the reality of
of how hard it is to do
and
how heroic it is to to do it and then
overcome and then actually in the end
achieve something create something that
that was really
it's almost it's almost not it's almost
not discussed
you